[موسيقى]
الصين في محاوله لمواجهه تحديات من ملف
تايوان الى الوجود العسكري الامريكي قرب
حدودها قررت رفع ميزانيتها العسكريه
لحوالي 224 مليار دولار ارقام تترجم توجها
صينيا جديدا تقول بكين انه يهدف لتعزيز
دفاعاتها القتاليه على مستوى العتاد
البشري بكين خفضت اعداد الجنود بشكل حاد
خلال العقد الماضي في اطار حمله تحديث
واطفاء طابع احترافي وتحسين الانفاق يضم
الجيش حاليا مليونين وخمسه مجند بين قوات
بريه وبحريه وجويه على مستوى العتاد
النووي تمتلك الصين حوالي 350 راسا نوويا
وسط اتهامات امريكيه سابقه بنيتها زياده
ترسانتها النوويه الى 1500 راس بحلول عام
على مستوى الاعداد الجوي تمتلك الصين
ثلاثه حاملات طائرات تعمل اثنتان منها فقط
حاليا والثالثه في مرحله اختبار في البحر
لكنها تصطدم بعراقيل لوجسيه وتقنيه معقده
اهمها تدريب العديد من الطيارين لجانب
محاولات حديثه لتطوير سلاحها الجوي باصول
مقاتلات حربيه
على مستوى العتاد البحري تفاخر الصين
بانها اول قوه بحريه في العالم من حيث عدد
السفن لكنه اسطولها يعتمد في الغالب على
فئات سفن اصغر على مستوى القواعد الخارجيه
لدى الصين قاعده عسكريه واحده فقط في
الخارج في جيبوتي تقول انها مخصصه بشكل
اساسي لعمليات مكافحه القرصنه رغم ما
تستعرضه الصين من عتاد عسكري الا انها لا
تزال متاخره في المنافسه مع الدول الغربيه
خاصه الولايات المتحده التي تفوقها عسكريا
بمراحل
وهو ما قد يضع هدف بكين على مسافه متاخره
جدا فيما يتعلق بالدفاع عن السياده او
اعاقه تدخل الولايات المتحده في المنطقه